your jeans are dirty you've just eaten a
kebab you look like a rat that's dressed
up to go to a gay club
absolutely not absolutely not I'm just
I'm not saying it's even a bad thing you
don't even say it's a bad thing I said
now you're trying to dig yourself out
I'm just saying well you are you're
trolling me because you think I look
like a gay rat and now you're trying to
dig yourself out of the fact that
dressed up to go to a gay club that's
what you look like the truth is you're
getting knocked out on July the first I
know exactly how the fight will go you
cannot touch me
I am here with two formidable people in
the property space and we are here for
something a little bit different today
than what they're used to we're here for
a very off the cuff very raw
conversation with a team these two
giants in the property world one giant
in the property world one giant in a
property World apparently about their
upcoming fights for charity a
three-round charity fight on the 1st of
July at the Brentwood center in Essex
now guys
your huge online massive online presence
but this is going to start attracting a
few people maybe outside of your space
so Samuel first maybe just explain to
the viewers that might be watching this
a little bit about yourself what you've
achieved in life and how you've got to
hear
yeah well basically win at everything
that I do I've got the biggest property
training company in the UK undeniably
your team are laughing there mate not
mine yeah undeniably
um and I've made a lot of money and Rob
challenged me to kick his ass so I said
yeah
Rob what about you sound uh yeah I have
1350 tenants 360 Property units 3.4
million rent roll I've written 18 books
um and I win everything I do including
this fight this fight's already won okay
so you're both extremely successful in
what you both do you both like to win at
everything what's the drive for this you
know you've achieved so much in life why
this and why now
well I've always wanted to punch Rob in
the face but now I can do it legally and
get paid for it
foreign
I didn't even notice Samuel before this
it wasn't even on my radar I know you
guys are laughing didn't even know he
was he saw my face every time he stepped
out your house bro sometimes sometimes I
went a mosquito sits on your bollocks it
gets annoying
so I just need to put him back in his
place he challenged me for the fight
it's in public record I was just doing
my thing he comes to Peterborough but
Billboard's up he stalks me out I think
he wants to be me I've been doing this a
lot longer than him I think he wants to
be me can't even grow the beard
genuinely look like a rat by the way
like actually look like a rat definition
that's a fast mate yeah they run a lot
like you're gonna be in on the on the
diet as well well you ain't catching me
yeah that's what you ain't catching do
you think all you're going to do is run
around that's it and you know what I'll
say you know my game plan already and
I'll tell you what I'm learning big
thing I'm learning I don't need to do
any weight training or anything like
that because I can knock you out I'm way
stronger I'm bigger what I'm learning is
how to corner a rat that's what I'm
learning yeah and I'm getting very good
at cornering and that's what's gonna
happen you're going to be running around
you're going to get cornered you're
getting ko'd you wait man you wait why
is your wife so afraid of you fine
begging me not to do it no she didn't
you again you have a problem you have a
problem
she's not begging me not to do it she's
not begging me not to do it she's
begging not to do it
she's a nervous laugh right there coming
through your wife didn't want you to
fight because she knows you're gonna get
kicked and um maybe she'll fall in love
with me after I kick
I would like to be in your head you got
some good dreams up there
but I'm already in your head you know
you've lost you've wriggled left right
and said oh what a really small ring oh
I want small gloves because I want the
Pontius charts to knock you out I won't
be I've got to travel a lot oh I can't
really do much training oh rubber please
go easy on me you're going down I'm
Gonna Knock You [__] out bang bang bang
bang you will not know what's hit you
and then in the middle of the third
round good night
and the truth is you're getting knocked
out on July the 1st I know exactly how
the fight will go you cannot touch me
yeah eating kebabs out there
yeah making excuses I'm away oh I really
fit it's really hard to do a two minute
round knocker in
you are going to a dark place Samuel
Leeds and there will be no one your boys
won't there
to help no one's taking you out this
dark hole I don't I don't think I'm
gonna have to do three three rounds I
think that's why you want to do less
rounds because you know you can't you
know the only way you can win is a lucky
punch you know it otherwise you'd had a
longer fight a bigger ring
it was obvious from day one what your
strategy is I know I can't run with him
I know I'm not as fit as him
so I'll have a lucky punch chance I'll
make a small ring let's fight in a phone
box let's have day enough
44. how old are you exactly are you sure
I'm 30. sure so you're 31. I'm 44 just
turned that's 13 years you just look
older and I don't get you I am how old I
am
just so you know
it looks the fact that you tell me I
look [__] means I know I look good your
jeans are dirty you've just eaten a
kebab you look like a rat that's dressed
up to go to a gay club yeah
yeah you're like a gay cowboy my friend
absolutely not absolutely not I'm just
I'm not saying it's even a bad thing you
don't even say it's a bad thing I said
are you trying to dig yourself out no no
I'm just saying well you are you're
trolling me because you think I look
like a gay rat and now you're trying to
dig yourself out of the fact that
dressed up to go to a gay club that's
what you look like a kebab out there you
were eating you were yeah I was you know
what because I'm I'm so unworried about
the fire I'm gonna finish you so easily
yeah I'm not even worried about my
kebabs I'm Gonna Knock You Out bro keep
dreaming keep dreaming how heavy are you
like 85 kilos so I'm 20 kilos heavier
I'm stronger 20 you said you were 120.
that's 40 kilos remember you don't know
how to tell the truth there's another
one I'm 110. I'll see 110 now but you're
what oh so is that 10 kilos 20 kilos 25
kilos
six foot three yeah not six foot outside
I'm six foot you're about six foot one
you know six it's not six three Bro Look
at that like an inch taller like a kid
yeah yeah yeah back to back
about an installer I'll afford to
Knocking you
come on
watch the equipment
yeah that's broken